[Music]
[Music]
so I don't think Jeff Bezos needs much
of an introduction you perhaps heard of
this small company he runs out of some
city in the west coast where there's
another company the I took a poll of the
faculty recently and and it's at a
faculty lunch and we were talking about
what people did online and I sort of
asked people questions and eventually I
said well how many of you have bought
something at amazon.com and it was
actually a hundred percent and I think
raised their hands I guarantee it was
not one of those any rate Jeff is a
graduate of Princeton and I'm pleased to
say he was telling me upstairs he
graduated from Princeton when it was
still an East and electrical engineering
and computer science department before
the department bifurcated and so he does
have an electrical engineering and
computer science degree and I think he's
he tells me he's glad he has one of
those and has he should be after leaving
Princeton he went to to Bankers Trust
worked there in the development of
computer systems so presumably if you
need help with code he can help you with
some of your programming and stuff of
that nature after that he went to de
Shaw well known for their high tech
approach to finance and in fact one of
two financial services companies three I
guess that belongs to our industrial
program in the department and then he
left de Shaw to start amazon.com and I'm
sure he can tell you more about that
than I can Jeff
okay thank you you guys it's great to be
here and so I start out telling you a
little bit about the founding of
amazon.com that I'm gonna do my favorite
thing which is to give a live website
demo this is the house where Amazon was
founded on the left-hand side here is
this little enclosed garage and I was
living in New York City working for
Deshawn Coe and came across the fact
that web usage was growing at 2,300
percent a year this was one of those
weird things where you could measure the
rate of growth without actually knowing
the baseline usage and people were doing
that because they could put sniffers at
various points at various nodes and they
could sort of see how fast the traffic
levels were growing past those nodes and
they could get a statistical sample of
those but they actually had no idea what
baseline usage was but you could look
around the web already in the spring of
1994 and see that it was big enough that
if it was growing at 23% 2,300 percent a
year pretty soon was gonna be huge and
so I you know kind of if we packed up my
wife and I and we flew to Fort Worth
Texas where my dad gave us a car 1988
Chevy Blazer which by the way Consumer
Reports recommends not to buy used under
any circumstances for any price and we
drove that car from Texas to Seattle
Seattle was chosen as the the best place
to start amazon.com because it was a
large pool of technical talent and also
nearby what at the time was the largest
book warehouse in the world in a town
called Roseburg Oregon and so we got
there my the first order of business was
to recruit a VP of engineering and I
talked to several people and I found the
guy I really liked his name was shale he
was with the company for six years and
was a he of you know huge instrumental
force in the company and in the early
days you know not single
of course but in large part led all the
software engineering that that was
amazon.com and he had nothing to do with
this you know the look of this website
though I'd like to get on that this is
what this is what our website looked
like when we launched in 1995 and I
wrote all of that HTML myself
please hold your applause and but but
shall [ __ ] part he wrote all of the
all the code that actually made it work
and but before hiring shel we're making
I I was making our deaths out of doors
and four-by-fours
and it took me three months to convince
shel to come join this company because
it was such a you know it's really just
a one-person company it was me and it
was a piece of paper and a name and the
name wasn't even Amazon at that time it
was Cadabra Cadabra
got changed because whenever I would say
to anybody over the phone they would
think I said cadaver and I realized that
wasn't going to work very well
Amazon was incorporated by the way by
Ike I didn't know I only knew two people
in Seattle so we were driving out there
I wanted to be moving fast well in the
company be incorporated by the time we
arrived so I called one of two friends I
had in Seattle and said could you
recommend a lawyer who could help me you
know get a company incorporated and open
bank accounts for the company and do
some stuff so I can hit the ground
running my friend said sure but so
amazon.com was incorporated by my
friends divorce lawyer not like some big
high-powered attorney and but anyway I
finally talked to shell into you know
coming and joining this intrepid
adventurer and but before he had moved
from the Bay Area up to Seattle he was
you know getting ready to do that move I
called him and I said so how tall do you
want your desk to be and because I'm
making him out of doors I bought at Home
Depot and four by fours and he was like
10 seconds of silence on the line and I
was thinking to myself oh great now he
realizes what a two-bit operation this
really is and he's gonna change his mind
he eventually answered the question and
about a year later I said shell you're
important I asked you
I'll tell you on your death to be
a year ago and you were quiet for like
10 seconds were you like reconsidering
your decision he said no I was just
considering how tall I wanted my desk to
be and so we got the software put
together took about a year to get the
software put together and to write this
astonishingly beautiful HTML and it's
really ugly isn't it it is and if you'll
see I think the next slide coming up
know that well this is our next row
this is what I don't have a what our
website looks like today but you guys
know what our website looks like today
you will note that has minor
improvements like a search box on the
whole on the on the on the main page
here you had to actually click through
to search you had to click on that link
that says 1 million titles so things
have gotten better by the way
since people don't know this but our
number one the number one thing we've
invested in amazon.com has been
technology and in fact since 1997 we
have in the last five years we've spent
800 million dollars on technology so
when you look at what what it is today I
look back at this that's that's what
eight hundred million dollars will buy
and we've only spent three hundred
million dollars on five million square
feet of fulfillment centers for example
and only six hundred million dollars on
marketing so technology has been our
single biggest investment and the
company basically runs on computer
science and it's either that or it's
just my bias since that's my background
but at any rate that's what we do is we
really focus on trying to differentiate
our experience with the with the
engineering and the algorithms that we
put into it so anyway we we got this
company just about ready to launch and
we're looking at it when looking at this
little tiny fulfillment center we were
here by then in this building we had a
basement fulfillment center to call it a
fulfillment center what's very grand
there's a lot of puffery it was four
hundred square feet which is about the
size of a one car garage and we launched
this business and we're looking at it
and we didn't
if anybody would order from us we really
didn't and in fact one of the software
engineers looked at this little space
and he said I can't figure out whether
this is incredibly optimistic or
hopelessly pathetic and indeed we didn't
know we had no idea whether anybody
would want to buy things in this way the
business plan called for generating
sales very slowly as customers changed
their attitudes the original business
plan which I thought was very optimistic
at the time called for amazon.com to
generate 70 million dollars in sales in
the year 2001 we actually generated an
excess of 3 billion dollars in sales in
the year 2001 and we knew by the way
that we were really onto something in
those first 30 days in the first 30 days
we got orders from all 50 states in 45
different countries with not a dollar of
advertising just all word-of-mouth the
first year we didn't spend anything on
advertising
all of it was word-of-mouth and that
really forged the company as a that we
were gonna focus on customer experience
cuz we saw the power of word-of-mouth so
so very very clearly in those early days
there's something great about word of
mouth online by the way and feedback
from customers which is that email turns
off the politeness gene in the human
being it's wonderful so people actually
tell you what they really think
usually in all caps and so we get lots
of info and feedback from our customers
and we try to try to use it well well in
that first few months we got one order
it was literally in the first six months
again where exactly was an order from
Bulgaria and I didn't even know they had
internet access in 1995 in Bulgaria but
they did and this person did not pay
with a credit card they paid with cash
yeah which is a method of payment we
discouraged and they had taken to crisp
$100 bills and folding them up in a tiny
little package and they took those $100
bills and put them inside a floppy disk
they opened the little metal door and
slipped them in the floppy disk and then
they mailed us the floppy disk
and on the note on the floppy disk was a
little note and it said the money is
inside the floppy disk and then it went
on to say the customs inspectors steal
the money but they don't read English
and so we opened up the little door sure
enough there was $200 in there they had
written their order number on it so we
could associate it with and they shipped
him their books and always well our
vision starting about it has changed a
little bit but it hasn't changed in
about four years about four years ago we
came up with the notion that we wanted
to be a place build a place where people
can come to find and discover anything
that they might want to buy on a line
literally Universal selection anything
with the capital a we had already been
on the path of trying to be what we call
Earth's most customer centric company
and we mean three things you have a very
precise definition for what customer
centricity is at amazon.com and it means
listen invent and personalise you and
the basic idea is you can't really run a
business of any kind I think in most
people's opinion if you're not going to
listen to your customers that's sort of
fundamental but invention is equally
important an invention that goes far
beyond listening to customers because
oftentimes customers don't really know
what it is that they want it's your job
to invent on their behalf and we've done
a tremendous amount of invention and
innovation of different kinds in the
company I'll show you a little bit more
about that when I give you the live live
demo and then finally personalization
the notion of customer centricity is to
build a place where each individual
customer has his or her own website and
to do that in large part not by explicit
information that the customer provides
but through implicit observation of
their behavior on the website so that we
personalize that experience based on the
actions that they take and we've put a
lot of effort on into that we've been
working on that 404 all but for the
first year of the company's operations
so for
I guess about six years now it's where
and a lot of some of our smartest people
have worked on that they're a bunch of
areas where we're we're good algorithms
and good heuristics and and so on turn
out to be very important for driving our
customer experience and that kind of
discovery accelerating discovery for
customers which is what personalization
is largely all about is critical when
you use this when you decide to be
selection intensive so we have over
twenty mean it's not 28 million or
something like that items in our catalog
we have in across all categories and and
it's not when you have so many items you
have to work hard to build tools that
help customers find products but you
also have to work hard and something
which is a little less intuitive and
actually a little technically even more
challenging which is to help products
find customers so we reverse the sense
of that we've put a lot of energy into
helping products find customers and it's
paid off this is the basic thing that we
work on every day so what we want to do
is have the world's best customer
experience and there are a few things
that feed into that massive selection
which requires great discovery tools and
low prices those are the two biggest
things low prices and both of those
things the heart of both those things is
technology it's very interesting because
I often get asked and it get made it's
just my bias because you know I'm an I'm
an X gig but how our business differs
from traditional retail and the answer
to that question I happen to know the
guy who does real estate for Starbucks
and believe me this is this is like the
guy who has the metaphorical corner
office I mean that business is all about
real estate this is why the old retail
saw the three most important things in
retail are location location location
and in our business it's technology
technology technology and one of the
great things about technology as opposed
to real estate is that real estate on
average economists will tell you we'll
get more expensive at the rate of
inflation so real estate gets more
expensive every year
and that's the core ingredient of
physical physical retailing whereas our
core ingredients get to follow Moore's
law so you know diskspace getting twice
as cheap every 12 months bandwidth
getting twice as cheap about at that
rate CPU every 18 months this is a
tremendous advantage and as those things
get cheaper and cheaper and cheaper in
and of themselves they don't offer any
real benefit to customers but what we
get to do is take all that compute power
and layer innovation on top of it to
really change the customer experience
game and that's a lot of fun we have
invested enough in our software that
we've become a more insert in a big part
of what we've done have become a more
classic e-commerce come more classic
technology company - or we actually now
service make available as a as an
application service provider using an
ASP model our e-commerce technology to
others and we're also I've done and I
think Rob is going to give you guys a
quick demo of our Web Services stuff in
a minute - we still doing that
competition oh good this is what instead
of our four hundred square foot
fulfillment center we now have five
million square feet of full of
fulfillment space it turns out that
operations research and all the logistic
stuff we do here is astonishingly
similar when I started learning about
these techniques I was like wait a
second this is computer science they
just have different words for everything
and we do one of the things that's very
interesting is in some of these
fulfillment centers we have two million
different items in the fulfillment
center and you can order any two of
those and somehow we have to marry those
two items together and get them into a
single box and ship them to you that
sortation is very challenging and there
are many pieces of it that are
challenging to do it in an efficient way
all the most obvious things you would
try first turn out they they work but
they don't work efficiently the cost
would be too high and what you end up
doing is you know is using very
sophisticated algorithms to calculate an
optimal
path through the fulfillment center and
you pick a bunch of customer orders at
once and just you and and and a
decentralized swarm of people actually
pick all these things and then they have
to get married in sort of a two-stage
sort later but the the picking
algorithms are like a dynamic Traveling
Salesman problem where the cities
occasionally move and disappear it's
it's like unbelievably it's it's it's
it's actually very fun and I didn't know
when I started the business I I thought
the front end of the business would be
very fun and intellectually stimulating
and had envisioned a lot of the kind of
personalization features that we could
build online but one of the things that
I had not known and not envisioned is
how intellectually stimulating inventory
optimization and pick path optimization
and these kinds of things would be -
this is you know kind of like airline
routing and so on it's it's a very
interesting problem we wrote our own
software for that so it's a great
question why don't what in fact we we
bought off the shelf inventory
optimization soft there is no good
picking software for the two million
items so that we built from the very
beginning the we did buy inventory
optimization software and it didn't work
very well for such a large skew base one
of the things that we found is that our
operations are significantly different
from most companies for a variety of
reasons your typical mail-order company
most of these things are made for like
you know warehouse management system and
made for mail order companies and you
can buy those things off the shelf but
they typically have a different number
of SKUs measured in the tens of
thousands and a lot of things change
when you scale that up to millions of
SKUs instead of tens of thousands of
SKUs and so we had to do a lot of
ourself we bought we early on we we
bought some personalization software
that also didn't work and one of the
things that's interesting about
personalization and that's where we've
put a huge amount of energy and
attention is that well first of all has
to work at scale with millions of
customers and in and you know on peak
days we will or you know take orders for
and ship two million
items and and and so it's very very
sensitive to doing that kind of do and
we do for unrecognized customers we do
real-time personalization based on their
clickstream and so there really is
nobody doing that the other thing is
that we can we can do active experiments
this is like a really big point that
most people miss but it's one thing to
take a huge data set and sort of do
backward looking data mining on it and
you can actually find some interesting
things that way but what's but what you
can't get from that is anything that has
a feedback loop where if you change
something changing that thing is it's
gonna change the customer behavior and
so one of the most fascinating kind of
tools we have at our disposal is the
ability to do active experiments it's
you know it's kind of this huge
laboratory with literally you know 30
million visitors a month coming through
and every time we make a little change
on the website we roll that change out
to a randomly selected group of people
and hold constant the rest so we make
you know we call it a B testing we may
do half the people C version a and half
C version B they're seeing it
simultaneously so we're holding all the
factors constant and we can actually
tell so if we develop a new
personalization algorithm that you know
some smart person inside the company
comes up with and they're really jazz
and they think it's better we never have
to argue about that we said well let's
try it and you know a few hours later we
will know whether it's better and that
is that is huge because this kinds of
arguments are so you know useless of
energy-draining come on up I'm gonna
introduce this this is this is Robert
Rock you're an alum and Roberts been
with us for quite a while how have you
been
three and a half years we've been to
Japan together we've been through
several trials together all men all good
things you've worked on our wireless
business and now you're doing a lot with
web services and let me turn it over to
you so again my name is Robert Frederick
I manage Amazon comms Web Services
program how many of you
of heard of web services or our doing
things with web services okay great
Amazon Web Services is something that we
launched this year in July we found that
by providing an API a solid SDK or an
API to our broad website developers as
well as our associates that we would be
able to get more and more users to
interact with our features all over the
Internet
rather than just that Amazon's website
so what we were thinking of doing is we
had we had three goals we wanted to
define a product and that product is the
ability to create your own store on your
own website to expose Amazon services
and features on I believe it at this
point in time is nine hundred thousand
websites that interact with us on a
day-by-day basis so what we were doing
is we were defining a capability to
interact get search results interact
with our similarities engine to find
products and to build those storefronts
on external websites all over the
internet in various countries all
through exposing a solid API and SDK so
again we had a market of 900,000
websites we have developers who wanted
to build soap packages scripts Perl PHP
you name it dotnet applications and we
wanted to provide those applications to
each one of these website owners so that
they can use our tools and interact with
us via soap or via XML over HTTP in a
very easy and viable solution so the
economic model for this as well or why
are we doing this why would Amazon will
ever want to expose the services that we
have on our site to all of these other
web sites on on the Internet and the
reason is very simple the more people
that are interacting with our
the more items that will potentially
sell and then we also have the
capability to provide these products on
their website in a way that you know
doesn't have to make them recreate the
wheel it's easy to implement literally
like you know anywhere between five
minutes to you know a couple of hours
and people are able to have a very
robust storefront a very robust way of
interacting with our products in our
selection so what we have what we ended
up doing was we came up with a soap
interface in an XML over HTTP interface
and I just wanted to go through a couple
of examples of some of the things that
people have built before turning this
over to Jeff again so so here is a very
simple script it's called Amazon Lite
simple search what we did here was we
provided a the capability for this one
developer to put this little search box
over here on his site and if I do a
search for dogs
sorry so as you'll notice over here on
the right and this is kind of cool
over here on the right when you type in
dogs you will be able to interact with
us in a very like quick manner send a
request over to us via XML over HTTP or
via soap it all depends on the backend
system that request is then parsed by
our back-end services where it retrieves
information from our back-end systems
our databases in our search engine and
then sends back an XML file to this
particular websites script they then use
that information and embed it into that
existing site the very cool thing down
here is it says QuickStart and this is
where people will be able to configure
their website offering down here by
answering a couple of these search
questions or these questions right here
and then they'll be able to copy the
code and just embed it into their site
and automagically
it now allows them to do search on their
own site with having without having to
actually build the whole search engine
the whole technology you click on that
link the link up here for these top
search results and you're brought over
to an Amazon site or you're brought over
to a Amazon Lite site that is powered by
that third-party let me go ahead and
click on one of the links so this will
bring you over to Amazon now the reason
or why in the world would anyone want to
embed this on their website
well we've tied the web services
offering to our Associates Program which
would allow the developer or the website
owner to earn a percentage for every
item sold on their site so every time
they're bringing a customer over to
Amazon they actually are given the
opportunity to earn a referral fee
anywhere between 5% and 15% of the
actual price of the item so there's like
a built in model a built in reason why
people would want to act want to use
this I know I only have a little bit of
time so I'm going to go really fast
so there's also a very interesting
implementation called
book search or book watch as soon as it
opens up and what this what this site
will do when it actually changes is it's
going to make a call to Google's web
services offering and Amazon's web
services offering as well as this other
web service offering called book watch
plus and it'll go or onfocus sorry and
it'll go through and find various topics
all on the internet via various people's
web logs then it'll call Google and then
determine like what the subjects are for
these people or the this particular
topic and then it'll call Amazon and
find products related to those books
that people are talking about in their
web logs so what you have here is an
opportunity to see the item that people
are talking about in the web logs to see
the news items that are all over the
Internet
concerning that particular item and then
to see Amazon's similarity engine being
used to provide products that people are
also buying on our website so this is an
amalgamation or a combination of three
different web services displaying a page
so that a customer would have a
different user interface that would
allow them to find out more information
or to have a different customer
experience a better customer experience
for the things that they're interested
in this is the surprised us type of
thing this is what we were very
interested in seeing people coming up
with new ways of consuming our web
services offerings to do things that we
had not even thought of ourselves and
then the last one is my favorite and as
Jeff said before well actually this
isn't last I'm gonna do one more but as
Jeff said before we we worked we we did
it something very interesting called an
AI mode launched in Japan which was for
our device access group that's also
a group that I managed and here in the
US that we found a company who knows
what's playing on any radio station all
across the u.s. now they have a web
service and but they don't have products
and they don't have a business model for
selling those products so what did they
do they actually came up with another
build a link or build a script type of
interface where individuals are able to
enter a city of frequency choose a
design this is actually what would
appear on any web site enter in an
associate ID that is that idea I was
telling you about before that would
allow us to track a purchase made and
then give credit to that particular
associate now the very interesting thing
about this is if I click on if I change
this to a different station didn't
someone give me a Boston station just
off the top of their head any chance any
Boston station MBR that's a tough one
can you nine what was it ninety-two five
things I needed a frequency MBR was
eighty eight point five or anyone yeah
that's right it's been a while this
one's taking a little bit of time
ah wouldn't you know when you're doing a
demo but one of the things that I was
trying to say here is that this
particular implementation is very unique
this is yet again another business model
that we had not thought of this one
provider this yes net whenever it does
come up here this flow web service is
not our website exactly
this you've got some standards this
particular web service offerings and I
don't know why it's not coming up right
now they came up with a model where they
give away their script for free and one
out of five links on the page will be
they will replace that person's
associated ID with their own associate
ID that way they're able to just earn
that revenue so they get 20% of the
exact revenue share and it shared all
across the internet where people who
have websites are able to embed this on
to their web on to their own websites
and not even have to worry about paying
for it because it's already built into
the system sorry here oh it was okay and
this is their little detail page where
you're able to see songs with clips
people who listen to this song also
listen to these songs it's been cool
I really like that one and then here are
if you here are some links over to our
website so if you want to see the last
few songs that were played you can see
the song name and then buy that album
from amazon.com very last and I promise
it'll be the last is a whole store a
whole store different from Amazon built
using our web services offering buy it
at a 21 year old German student who just
wanted to play with it and see what he
can build and he was able to build this
simple camera shop
in a matter of I believe three hours
that's what he said and he he did
something over here where you're able
[Laughter]
yeah well anyway what I was gonna show
was are you sure that I have a
connection here but what he what he has
at this point is the ability to compare
products this is what this line over
here is and if you would press this Go
button and then the next page would
allow you to see a comparison across all
the different products with a check mark
and I just wanted to show that hopefully
we have we still have a connection so
let me bring it back over to Amazon so
one of the really cool things about
doing web services for amazon.com okay
this is looking better is that we have a
competition going on right now for
developers students people all across
the country to be involved in where
we're giving away $5,000 to the best
storefront builder developed by a
developer or student or whatever the
case may be I have some more information
about that so if anyone afterwards would
be interested in learning more about the
competition about Amazon Web Services
about device access or just anything at
all just come and see me thank you thank
you all very nice
there's one more there's one more thing
that I wanted to do and I wanted to
recognize some of the people who we have
given offers to we are still hiring of
course one of the let me just I don't
know if everybody everyone on the list
is here today but these are some of your
classmates who have job opportunities
with us and hopefully they'll join Allen
McConnell is he here buddy - okay Alex
Dinu Joe Hastings Andrew Sutherland
Jonathan Bruns Minh and Nicholas
Hansen's
so I don't know if you know these people
but we're very excited about them having
the opportunity to come join our company
thank you and if you if you win the web
developers contest then you can have a
Segway it's $5,000 it's perfect all
right I'm just going to show you a few
things I I want to first I'll show you
I've been talking a lot about
personalization I can you know it's
really some of the most impressive
things that our architects and engineers
have done actually doesn't demo well
because a lot of it has to do with
scalability and what happens if a
particular service goes down you know
how does it feel gracefully and some of
these things are very complicated to do
but not that interesting to demo but if
I come in let me look at my
recommendations for a second and I'll
tell you a story the very first time now
it wasn't the first time but one of the
first times that I read that I demoed
recommendations live with a live web
site I was being too a group of Wall
Street analysts and and my number one
recommendation number one personal
recommendation was the DVD called slave
girls beyond infinity
which was this is much less embarrassing
and you never know what you're gonna get
I never know exactly what I'm going to
get because it is live and it does
change you know from minute to minute
but I'm glad to see that today I've
gotten you know Apollo and then I can
see of course why was I recommended this
because I bought cosmos and angle of
attack and another book called Apollo so
but slavegirls beyond infinity I'll just
show you was was a little embarrassing
what happened to that laser pointer
thing oh here it is do not look directly
into me okay
and there it is slave girls from beyond
infinity just go over here this is
pretty interesting it's so you can buy
this DVD with assault of the killer
bimbos
by together it's only 1996 all of that
product clustering is done automatically
of course it the you come down and
you'll notice that you know customers
who bought slave girls also bought
sorority babes in the slimeball
bowl-o-rama and my personal favorite
cannibal women in the avocado jungle of
death and there's this interesting thing
here we we even know when things are
part of a series so we say and also they
bought DVDs from the barbarian queen
series so we can quick through a quick
click through and look at the barbarian
queen and there's a customer review here
it says for Lena Clark's and fans only
this is barbarian queen - this is not
even barbarian queen
it's an incredibly bad film whose only
redeeming feature is laying at Clarkson
in and out of some skimpy outfits
she's completely gorgeous but even she
can't save a disaster of a film then
here comes the great recommendation by
Deathstalker instead in fact were you
trying to be funny
no I didn't think so no it's not it's
very interesting we use a technique
called random stow so all the items in
the warehouse are stowed randomly there
is no rhyme or reason as you yeah
they're hashed so as you walk through
they all have locations they all have
bins so you know where everything is but
only the computer knows where everything
is as you walk through it'll be you know
slave girls from beyond infinity right
next to you know dr. Seuss you know
they'll be side by side and so it does
make walking through does it does is
like an incredibly eclectic experience
when you go walk through the fulfillment
center but these similarities are
incredibly hard to compute
you know and there's a lot of stuff you
have to look at how much information
theory there is in each I mean how much
information there is an each purchase
because the you know you don't want you
know if you do the simple
straightforward thing then every book
just recommends oh and customers who
bought this also bought Harry Potter and
that's not very interesting so you have
to take that into account you have to do
a lot of things and we have to compute
millions and millions of these we have
to do it very rapidly and we like to do
it on small machines so we figure out
how to do that and only two gigabytes of
RAM so there's a lot of there's a lot of
cool stuff along that there was a great
similarity I remember one time I was
looking at this book and it was a book
on Zen and I looked down at the list of
similarities customers who bought this
book on Zen also bought and there were
five or six similarities as there
usually are and five of the six were
other books about Zen and then the sixth
one was how to have a clutter free desk
and that's the kind of connection that
only a computer can make I mean no human
editor it's going to say they would
always pick six other books on Zen but
you know people who like Zen also buy
books on how to have a clutter free desk
and that comes out let's see and show
you one of my favorite features I can
show it's just about any product I
bought so many things on the site I'm
going to show you the Aqsa salad spinner
in our kitchen store here is the Aqsa
Good Grips salad spinner now this is
interesting for a couple of reasons but
one is that the customer reviews on this
product read like a sexual experience I
mean people love the Aqsa sound like
people who don't eat salad love the Aqsa
salad spinner
that's how how potent of a product this
is and we do a couple of things here
that are interesting one is you can see
here it says these friends have
purchased these items these are mine
these are my
of mine and so you know as long as we're
here and as long as I've already
identified my friends we might as well
whenever I stumble across something I
get to see which of my friends have
bought this thing by the way doing that
in real time isn't that easy remember
this is a big decentralized system with
thousands of web servers and you don't
want to go back we have what happens is
we as a pub sub technology and when you
first come to our website the instant
you're recognized
we sent we publish a message to all of
the different services that subscribe
the ones that subscribe to that message
recognize it and they start immediately
the second you hit our gateway they
start filling a high-speed cache of
everything that might be interesting
that you might want to see on this visit
to the store so that's one of the ways
that we're able to do you know millions
and millions of visits provide this
level of personalization and
customization and have it not be really
really slow the other thing that was
very personalized on this page and this
is I told you earlier that we very
carefully tasked all of our features and
you know and when we do this testing we
have a very simple objective function
it's it's a little more complicated than
this but basically our objective
function is you know we prefer the thing
we're if we're testing feature a against
feature B we like the one that generates
more sales you know we're pretty
simple-minded in that regard and but
this what I'm about to show you is one
of the few features we've ever left on
the website even though with statistical
significance it slightly reduces sales
and it's called the instant order update
so you can see up there at the very top
it says Jeff Bezos you purchased this
item on May 16th mm so you no more than
two years ago I bought the oXXO salad
spinner
now with salad spinners it doesn't
happen very much but with music CDs and
a whole bunch of other products people
forget they bought them and they buy
them a second time
so they're like you know I don't
remember if they buy that Madonna CD and
then they're like they get it home or
maybe they never notice it but they buy
it accidentally a second time and all of
us do this I mean unless you're like
incredibly organized or something it's
like hard to avoid this if you do so you
know you're busy but people buy books a
second time and so on so on and so
anyway we thought about this and we
thought well what we can do
unlike any other store anywhere in the
world is every time you come to a page
if you've already bought it
we'll just tell you then he won't buy it
a second time and we even though this
slightly reduces sales we get so much
positive feedback from this we get so
many email messages to customer service
where people said I was just about to
buy that Enya CD a second time and I
didn't thank you it's like they're
thanking us because they didn't buy
something what's that well you know the
amazing thing is most people don't
return things very much even you know
what they will do because it's a bit of
a hassle to return something if they got
a second copy of that Enya CD typically
they would give it to a friend or
something they don't really want it but
it's not for an expensive item yes
people would return it but people also
tend to keep track of their you know
they're not going to say oh I already
bought a digital camera
Oh
silly me that's right I have a Segway
shoot but for you know a twelve dollar
CD people don't put the same amount of
attention on it so anyway I just show
you this is just amazing to me every
time I look at this there are new
reviews so this one was only written on
November 9th and it's from this guy
named Warren holls holls them this is
one heck of a spinner
I've darn near got enough to centrifuge
speeds with just a few easy pumps great
for drying off all kinds of fruits and
vegetable and it just goes on and on
literally there are no let's see it
should say down here I don't know how
many customer reviews there are but
there are hundreds you know they well
here the list of 74 so but don't know
why they're only 74 I thought there were
more but anyway there are 74 customer
reviews here look this one is labeled
sand from Georgina this is a very good
spinner at a good price most of the
previous reviews are dead on except they
neglect to mention that this spinner
does the great job of removing sand from
red lettuce and other exotic greens
including dandelion radish
not to mention spinach I bought it for
that reason alone it's some people are
it's just fanatical salad spinners look
at this it's all five-star reviews oh
here's somebody good but questionable
durability this is you know there's
always one in the crowd here and you're
good and we can sort these reviews we
use it's not a totally straightforward
algorithm but we can basically we're
trying to put the reviews if you come
back to the main page some of the top
reviews are from people who've gotten
lots of helpful votes so you can always
review vote was this review helpful to
you yes or now one of the nice things
about voting on amazon.com is we have
customer identity because you know
everybody who's using our system has a
credit card number and so we can kind of
keep track of we don't let like somebody
stack the deck and vote 100
I mean I guess they could if they have a
hundred different credit card numbers
and a hundred different accounts but you
know it's not really worth stacking the
deck for the salad spinner to get so
many credit cards well I guess that's
true if you make it then why not if
you're make it and you're evil we did
have we did have it was very funny we've
we have we do remove them and I often
think we should at least build a
graveyard for them somewhere but we do
have people who who put up spoof
customer reviews and they're hilarious
we've had God review the Bible we had we
had remember we had a camera which
Bronte sister it is the one who really
hated Jane Austen it was either Emily or
Charlotte does anybody know is it Emily
and so we had Emily where there were a
few years ago there were like there were
like two miniseries and a full-length
motion picture based on different Jane
Austen novels it was just a few years
ago and somebody started put somebody
started posting customer reviews
pretending to be Emily Bronte and she
was just like I hate Jane Austen to
miniseries in a full-length motion
picture in one year yeah they were it
was quite amusing but we take those down
and we also had one guy who said his
review was incredibly honest it wasn't a
spoof but it was also kind of like
damning with faint praise his review
started out this is the best book my
brother ever wrote like golly
tough family there unlike all my other
brothers books this one might be worth
reading so let's see I don't know I
might just switch over to Q&A you know
once you go in I can show you the page
you made this is the real time
clickstream stuff it's more useful for
customers who we don't recognize but
it's you know trying to make sense of
these bizarre pages that we've looked at
the dog listener slave girls and the
oxxo salads
we're not giving it much to work with
here but but it's recommending the
microplane grater zester which by the
way I have that product that's a great
product and it's recommending assault of
the killer bimbos The Dog Whisperer it's
also recommending the mini salad and
herb spinner so if you need a herb
spinner and addition to your salad
spinner but I think I will end the demo
there and let me see if I can give back
I don't really even need this the
customer recommendations are based on
what we're trying to do is get the
probability what we want is to increase
the probability that somebody will add
an item to their order even if it's an
inexpensive item so it actually turns
out to work in our interest so what
we're trying to do is we look at for
personalization we basically calculate
you know for every customer a
probability that they will what's the
most likely product that you will buy
and then we try to take out the most
obvious you know sort of low information
content products like Harry Potter or
some because you probably you've already
run across that a hundred times in other
ways in the supermarket and everywhere
else so putting that in front of your
something gonna say Oh Harry Potter four
is out you know you'd have to be living
under a rock so so that is but we try to
get the things that are a little bit
more obscure products and then and then
within that we optimize those algorithms
and we're certainly doing it out of our
own self-interest I mean we're not you
know with there's no question we are in
this business to make money but the way
that we do it is by trying to help
customers make purchase decisions and if
you can do that and in small ways as
well as I showed you at the instant
order of day we've been willing to
accept some features that decrease sales
but that's because we're long-term
oriented we believe that if we give up
those small amounts of sales today the
people who are reminded not to buy the
Enya CD a second time
we'll think that we're so great that
they'll come back and buy more in the
future so it's just you know it's a very
simple model which is if you if you if
you treat customers right try to do the
right thing and actually provide real
value great prices we've been very
focused on cost structure making the
prices so that we can afford to lower
prices so we've got you know free
shipping on orders over $25 30% off
books over $15 great product prices on
electronics and DVD players and digital
cameras and so on and and we're the only
place you can buy the Segway human
transporter now I realize this is a
little out of reach of your average
undergrads budget but nevertheless it's
a cool cool product and then you know I
just like to offer up my email address I
won't answer your email if you email me
but I will forward it I do read my
emails and if anybody is interested we
are always looking for you know the best
of the best in terms of engineering
talent computer science talent so if you
have any interest at all you know you
can email me and I'll I'll ship it off
right away to the right people anyway
with that I will end and I'll open it to
questions and however much time we have
I'll leave that up to you and and who's
got a question yes please
something about different customers
receiving different prices on the same
problem yeah we did a and a B test with
best-selling DVDs or what we did was we
took what we wanted to determine was the
shape of the of price elasticity in
best-selling DVDs so what we did was we
randomly took we actually subdivided
customers into three groups just based
on like the last digit of their customer
ID so was completely random and we
showed some people 30% off some people
35% off and some people 40% off but what
happened is the press got this all
confused and they believed that there
was some devious algorithm where we were
trying to charge like people in rich zip
codes more like you know trying to which
we weren't trying to do we were actually
just trying to determine the shape
elasticity curve but it was so confusing
for people that we decide not to run
that kind of experiment so we still do
all the a/b tests but we do them with
features we don't do them with prices
yes things that you know are very simple
basics like treat your customers well
didn't you develop all these great
innovations and I'm wondering is that
all internal and customer base or do you
benchmark against traditional companies
and how do you keep this sort of spirit
of innovation alive well that is a truly
great question
the first of all the way to get a lot of
innovation in a company in my opinion is
to try and is to work very very hard to
reduce the cost of doing experiments
because the problem is if experiments
are expensive then very few people are
going to get to do very few experiments
that's just the way it works so if you
have a big group of very creative people
which we do we have a tremendous number
of smart people who love to innovate on
behalf of customers and vente news
things you've got to set up this kind of
like what I was sorry about the a/b
testing framework something like that so
that if somebody comes up with a new
personalization algorithm
I think will outperform the current one
you don't have to you know move heaven
and earth to get it tried so it's
important to reduce the cost of
experimentation and then to have some
objective standards about what's better
than what if you can do that then you
can do a lot of innovation now some of
the things that we experiment with are
really hard to do and the cost of
experimentation is high so for example
we don't really and and with consumer
behavior you know it is based with
anything totally new it is really very
difficult anywhere between very
difficult and impossible to guess how
consumers are gonna behave how a mass
audience is going to do anything in the
future is very hard to determine the
easiest way to determine it is just to
do it and see what happens and I think a
lot of companies get that wrong they put
too much energy into like you know
arguing about how consumers are gonna
behave and by the time they're done
arguing they could have just done it and
see what see what happened and so
sometimes like we but we spend a huge
amount of effort building customer
self-service tools so the customers
could cancel their own orders and and we
did some research up front in the kind
of classic way to try and determine
whether customers would want to do this
and we got some encouraging results but
focus groups and things like that are
fraught with peril they're the people
people don't know really typically what
what they will do if you ask them what
you think they'll do they'll try to tell
you the truth but they don't really know
and so we decided to just take the
gamble there was no way to build this in
a simple way and sort of do a/b tests
that we could think of so we just went
ahead and built you know some heavy-duty
infrastructure to allow people to cancel
their own orders by the way internally
we argued about should we let people
cancel their own earners you know these
are the kinds of things you get you get
cold feet about you're like maybe they
will cancel their orders and and maybe
we'll have no sales you know but in fact
of course if you give people more
control you know our basic theory was if
you give people more control over their
environment if they know they can cancel
their own orders then maybe the order
more and in fact you know it that seems
to have been correct that by giving
people these
these self-service tools we're
empowering them and they seem to like
that but that was an example where he
couldn't really do a low-cost experiment
kind of had to build the whole thing in
order to test it yes companies were able
to look to see from their organization
what people were buying and I'm
wondering with all of the
personalization issues do privacy issues
like that I'm not sure what's your I
think you're referring to purchase
circles which actually has been quite
successful so I'm not sure before
purchase circles this is a very long
time ago there was a news story
Xerox look to see what but its employees
of are buying somewhat yeah but that's
still up there you can do that no no no
no Xerox can't look to see what their
employees are buying and I and I don't I
don't doubt Slashdot reported that with
what you're thinking of I know exactly
what you're thinking of is that we
aggregate the data and so companies can
opt out if they want but like I think
like four companies have opted out you
can go online I could show you and you
can see like what are the best selling
books from people who you know at
mit.edu you can go online and see what
are the best selling books at you know
from amazon.com employers or from
Microsoft employees and so on and so on
but we have rules about aggregation and
we did from the very beginning so unless
the group is at least 250 customers we
don't aggregate that we don't put the
data out there
I think it's 250 it's some large number
so the people can't back into who bought
what so and it turns out to be really
cool data to see you know what these
companies are buying what the best
seller list is and we do it
geographically so you can go in and look
at you know see what's the best selling
book in Matt and what are the best link
books in Massachusetts and we do not
only best-selling but we do a special
algorithm we call uniquely best-selling
to sort of scrape away all the Harry
Potter's and so on so you can see what's
uniquely best-selling in Massachusetts
what's uniquely best-selling in Boston
what's uniquely best-selling in
Cambridge what's uniquely best-selling
at Harvard
what's uniquely best-selling at MIT and
he can compare those and it's actually
kind of fun and then we put the best
Arliss wheat then we tie that back to
the detail pages so if you're stumbling
around you looks find a detail page you
may see something like this is the
number seven bestseller at MIT edu and
it's anyway that I think that's what
you're thinking open at that time we
didn't make money off books either the
question was why why did we expand into
things like electronics tools in kitchen
since those businesses are not today
profitable and the answer is that well
that it increases our addressable market
size so we can ultimately build a much
larger company by entering into those
new product categories and and second
while it's true that those new
categories which are only three years
old and by the way electronics tools in
kitchen is now a six hundred million
dollar business at amazon.com which
makes it one of the largest on its on a
standalone basis it's probably in the
top four or five ecommerce companies
anywhere in the world so that business
is growing and growing very rapidly and
it has it one of the big advantages it
has it has a huge audience of early
adopters which is why companies like
Segway choose us as the exclusive launch
platform for products like that because
really early adopters are the kind of
people who buy stuff like this so it's
but that business ultimately will be
electronics in particular in my opinion
will be our largest most profitable
business one day when you start a new
business there are certain fixed costs
that come along with starting that
business and then the business has to
reach enough scale so that the profit
from the business the variable profit
can cover those fixed costs there's no
sidestepping that and it's just a simple
investment issue the company now in the
LAT in a trailing 12 month basis
generated 120 million dollars in free
cash flow after interest expense
so it's you know and and really were
just at break-even the company is doing
very well financially yeah in the back
how do you deal with the new
technologies going out there and how do
you compete against that despite the
fact that you guys already invest a lot
internally well really that is them I
mean the good news from a technology
investment point of view is that
compared to most of our competitors
well actually really I guess compared to
all of our competitors we're spending so
much more you probably have to add up
the next ten eat Ahlers together to get
anywhere near our technology spending
budget so at 200 million dollars a year
you know most of our competitors don't
have 200 million dollars in sales so
they can't spend 200 you know we have 4
billion dollars in sales so 200 million
dollars a year is just 5% of sales you
know at Barnes and noble.com 200 million
dollars would be half of sales so that's
a a significant advantage for us as we
continue to build out we want the gap
between our customer experience and
those of our competitors actually
widened you know with with these kinds
of personalization features and and
there's lots of stuff that I can't talk
about on the drawing board that we think
is gonna make the experience you know
much much better in the future
well we the question was of that 200
million how much of it is R&D I never
know exactly how to answer that question
I mean oh as opposed to disk drives
almost all of it is I mean there's very
little the good news is you know we're a
total Linux platform and you know so
it's very cheap it's all commodity
hardware we have a few big database
servers but you know this stuff has
gotten so cheap I don't know exactly
what the fraction is but a lot of a big
fraction of that expense is as people
expense it's you know smart people yeah
well there are there are two groups of
competitors there that our big
competition is in the physical world so
if you in there and we online is still
so small it's let you know retail sales
worldwide or five trillion dollar market
and so an online is you know less than a
percent of that it's very very tiny
today so you know you don't want to take
sales away from online competitors just
because there isn't that much sales to
take away so you look at physical all
the sales are in the physical world so
that's where the dollars are that's
where you need to focus your primary
competitive energy the the you look at
online companies not because you want to
get their sales but because sometimes
you might be able to learn from them I
mean they're watching customers to
hopefully and and and so you need to see
what they're doing how are they
innovating what are they thinking of
what kind of lessons can we learn from
that incorporated into doing things the
way we do things rarely by the way have
I seen it successful online to do direct
copies of things usually you get some
inspiration from something but then you
have to kind of make it your own and and
and in you make it be part of doing
things the way we do things for our
customers so in in and then once you're
in the physical world the big
competitors there's a different one for
every category so we would look at you
know Best Buy in electronics as our top
competitor Best Buy in the physical
world Barnes and Noble in books and you
can go right down the line in every
category and you can it's usually the
kind of the the selection intensive you
know superstore type competitor defined
by category information that example I
know many product designers you know for
baby toys you know go to Amazon they
look up their customers
you figure out how people feel about it
and I'm wondering so now I were to start
a web use the web services from Amazon
for trying to resell it repackage it you
know sort of how did you guys what's
that interplay the answer is right now
you have to try and use the web services
as part of our Associates Program so the
there's a contract you sign when you do
when you sign up to get a developer
token there's some there's some rules
and one of the things you cannot do is
download the data and repackage it for
the sort of purposes that you're talking
about and you can't cache the data
there's there's several things that that
you know because the data is valuable we
don't want you to just to write a
program that like sucks all the data out
and then you know then it's your data
that can't be but you do but if you're
you know playing by the rules of being
an associate you can invent a lot of
cool stuff you know you own that stuff
you read the contract you know you own
your application and the things you
build on top of it we just reserve the
right to you know kind of take the data
back yeah do some more down here in
front desk top desktop yes what's what's
uniquely interesting about that world
that makes so the question is is the
mobile wireless world interesting
presentation logic how to write the I
think the answer is that that world is
not very interesting today with the
exception of Japan where for whatever
reason it's worked a lot better and
people are willing to you know the real
problem is the devices so the devices
have very small input device a versatile
output device and as we get to see
better web pads that you know like this
is a great device the BlackBerry for
doing email is this is not my most value
but I give him my cell phone before I
would give up my blackberry and that
that you will
see devices with this sort of form
factor with decent input devices that
have you know decent color screens with
enough resolution so you can actually
look at enough data to actually do
something on the web right now you know
if you're using your cell phone to do
things on the web you know you're like
you know hitting the three key three
times to get a particular I mean it's
just it's just bad it's a bad customer
experience it's the best you can do
perhaps with that physical device but
that stuff will get better and that's a
pretty big deal the thing that's a
bigger deal in the shorter term is more
people getting instant on at home it's
not even the extra bandwidth that you
get at home it's the fact that you can
leave your computer on I think the thing
that will happen next is that people
will have multiple computers in their
home so I already see that starting to
happen we know one of our best selling
electronics products for years has been
wireless routers a lot of people
installing 802 11 networks in their home
and it's and it completely changes your
behavior when you get you know two or
three or four computers in your house
instead of sort of one in the office or
one in the bedroom or whatever it is so
when you look at your average household
you know you're gonna start to see that
the number of computers just like with
phones there was a time when people said
you know why would anybody ever have two
phones in their house that's sort of
ridiculous absurd luxury and now people
put a phone in every bedroom they put
them in their bathrooms they put them in
their kitchens they you know they put
them everywhere in the kitchen is
actually the key room so I put a
computer in my kitchen and it doubled my
amazon.com purchases
I I strongly recommend you need an
instant-on computer in your kitchen that
will be a big deal not serve behavior
when you're in the kitchen different
enough that into consideration and
making even company by making what
recommendation recommendations I hadn't
thought about that
recommendations by room right we need to
be able to impute your room though
otherwise we'd have to ask people what
room are you in or have you like
register your computer this is my
kitchen computer will make the Ox of
salads been a recommendation in there
yes what I think is my position on this
is very clear which is I think patents
in general are really very good and you
know if you look at the kind of the
history of the Patent Office and of
innovation in this country it's hard to
unlink the two and now the one of the
things that I think is if you look back
historically the rate of change was
slower so if you look at the lifetime of
a patent it's actually increased a
little bit because of some international
treaties and it's basically gone from 17
years to 20 years the and for some
industries 20 years is a very
appropriate lifetime so for example if
you are you know manufacturing a new
pharmaceutical you probably need you may
need 20 years you know you've got to go
through ten years of FDA testing and you
know there's all this stuff going on you
may need a long lifetime to recoup your
R&D costs and you need you know you need
some exclusive period where all that R&D
benefits only you and but when you look
at software patents it seems to me that
20 years maybe too long and so that's
the point I made and yeah this it's
really the same thing but but it's it's
I would say that there is no chance of
that changing and the reason is when you
go look at this and I I did I actually
went to Congress and I made my case in
front of a few people that this seemed
like too long a period
and the the problem is this thing is now
so well-established not just in the US
but via international treaty you know
literally hundreds of Nations that have
all entered into mutually binding patent
treaties and it's very hard to get that
whole web of stuff change so that's why
it's it's people tend to leave it alone
yeah so getting stuff to me that it
seems like you know your business will
scale your computers will scale but the
you know one roadblock between me buying
stuff on Amazon all the time she's
getting that stuff from Washington to to
my home and you know I applaud you all
for making that $25 free shipping stuff
I think it's amazing I don't know how
you do it but where do you think that's
gonna go like how do you think those
cost scales because well it's a great
question the question basically is is
there some way to you know dramatically
change the delivery part of the business
model so that you are and the answer is
at certain scale levels maybe so already
it's changed a lot because we first
started we shipped only out of Seattle
you know now we have you know five but
you're not gonna have one in every city
well why not did you get the hospital
well it's all question of scale the
question was you're not gonna have one
in every city and you probably won't
have one in every city but you very well
might have one and I mean you need a lot
of scale at four billion dollars in
scale we've got the right number of
fulfillment centers right now but if you
take that from 44 billion to 40 billion
things would start to change
significantly
you'd probably put it in New Hampshire
[Laughter]
well the well that's why you should shop
at Amazon you're looking particularly
handsome today
it's the the it is no the $25 Super
Saver Shipping is incredibly expensive
so it has to be it's the most expensive
price reduction we've ever made and
we're still hopeful by the way that we
will leave it in place permanently we're
gonna make a decision at the end of the
year about whether to make it permanent
we were at $49 if we can't make $25
permanent we'll go back to 49 but I'm
very hopeful we can make the $25 level
permanent and the key there is being is
be is being very efficient so it the
economics can be made to work it's just
a question of does it generate enough
incremental lift in volume to justify
the huge price reduction that it
effectively is yes if you were a 2002
college graduate you know with your
newly minted engineering degree what are
some of the fields you'd be most
interested in working in newly minted
2002 college student with an engineering
degree what are some of the fields that
I would be most interested in working in
well you know I think first of all what
I would say is you you the best advice
and gift somebody is do something that
you think is interesting and let the
waves catch you you know something that
I see people do which I don't think is
is a good idea is they try to chase the
current thing I saw this so much in 1997
in 1998 1999 with respect to the
internet there were you know in 94 and
95 96 97 the mostly the people who were
you know the kind of the earlier you get
the more true this is but you know the
people who were sort of looking at this
space and starting companies were
genuinely interested in it they thought
it was really cool by the time you got
to 1999 well
doctors were stopping you know screw
that doctor thing I'm gonna start a
dot-com company you know and so that
really made no sense whatsoever you know
people were sort of abandoning the
things they were genuinely interested in
trying to catch a wave and whenever you
try to catch a wave if you're almost
always too late so it's it's better to
just I mean if you're paddling after it
you basically have to wait in place and
let it come to you and so just to just
sprang something that you're passionate
about
I would definitely on the career advice
side the most important thing about your
first job out of school is to pick a
place where you think you're gonna
you're learning per unit time is gonna
be very high you can optimize for a
bunch of variables and it can get very
confusing you know where it's location
you know what's the salary going to be
and all those things are worth
considering they're all important but
make sure you pull back after you've
done your analysis and say am I also
picking the place that I believe my
learning per unit time is gonna be the
fastest and you learn much more from a
best practices company than you do you
learn no matter where you go so if you
go work for somebody you're like god
these people are all crazy this is
insane you'll learn a lot of negative
lessons that you can use later and you
can not do those things but that process
of elimination method takes a long time
so it's better to try and find a place
has really high hiring standards some of
the basics especially you know a place
that's trying to recruit only the you
know the you know is hire A's and B's
higher seas and C's higher D's so you've
got to hire only A's and you need to
pick a company that's doing those kinds
of fundamental practices well because
then you'll learn so much it'll set you
up to do other things so I would say
that's probably the best career advice
again time for one more question okay
yeah
the sights are similar yeah our
international sights are similar it's a
very good question and I'm very pleased
to note that you have found the sites to
be similar because we we insist all of
our software development is done in
Seattle
we don't allow any software development
to be done we have we do have big
physical operations and great marketing
teams and so on outside of the US but
the software is so core and so expensive
to do well that you want to have exactly
one set of source code that gets used
all over the world globally and many
companies have you know made the mistake
of allowing their you know different
sets of source code in different
countries to go out of sync and they end
up with two completely different systems
now they're getting no fixed cost
leverage across those two systems
they've got two different teams
developing two different systems and
then they decide one day this is
terrible and stupid how do we let this
happen and then they want to recombine
those systems and the systems by that
point have diverged so much the
recombining them is very difficult so
it's it's very important to have one
sort of source code around the world and
and and and that's thank you for
noticing that we do that we did but the
software that runs the the fulfillment
centers is also the same all over the
world so the key is you know what
happens to software software is
fascinating in a business because not
only do you you know you do all the
things that you're trying to do but some
stuff what happens is business knowledge
gets overtime embedded in the software
so little bits and pieces the software
ends up knowing this is my opinion again
I admit to being sort of computer
centric but in my opinion the at the end
of the day the software knows more about
your business than you do and so it's
really important that you only have one
such system because it's going to be
complicated and it's going to be
very interesting and it's gonna have
lots of knobs and it's gonna and the
reason it has all the snobs because it
knows a lot about your business thank
you you guys
[Applause]